do you like that in-between time
Jonathan when you have nothing going on
there just like this big question mark
in the air like what am I going to do or
do you like more certainty honest answer
I look I just love working so if I could
go and I would tell my manager Nagant
this if I could go back to back to back
to back to back to back to back that's a
vacation I mean I don't really need a
vacation time I love working and I'm
young and I have the energy to do it and
I just want to put good stuff out there
so yes sometimes it's hard because I
wanted like do everything but you got to
really be you know you got to be picky
and do the right stuff and choose wisely
and do stuff that really speaks to you
but at the same time I just I want to
work constantly and why else does it
work for you aside from the fact that
you like being on set you like being
around the crew and everything you were
saying earlier yeah I feel like
everything in my life you know the all
the daily stresses and anxiety tends to
go away when I'm working when I can
really focus my energy and put all this
this positive thinking into a project
and it really for me is a positive thing
working
then everything seems to always be
better for the times that you don't have
something going on what do you do to
drum up either work or your own projects
you know I I really like I make my own
content shorts and and and stuff like
that I'll do shorts with my friends I
like to do martial arts in my free time
I love my dog I love to hang out my
family my family's all in LA so that's
really nice and to drum up work I mean I
was just out there like everyone I'm
still part of the audition game out
there auditioning all the time so that
and acting classic go to acting class a
lot and focus on that and theater I do
theater when I can so it's just you know
it's I'm trying to do something every
day to be better at what I do I always
say you don't go you know you don't see
NFL players get into the NFL and they
stop practicing I think it's the same
thing with acting and III can always get
better since you grew up in the LA area
you probably saw so much happen I know
you're still so
so young but I'm sure you got a great
perspective of how this industry works
and ups and downs what's your take on it
because you still love it and you're
still active
is there a mantra you tell yourself is
there something is there a perspective
that you have that keeps you feeling
fresh about it there is a certain
lifestyle as far as working and
constantly being working and certain
goals I have and I always tell myself
I'm like I want this certain lifestyle
and I will attain this certain lifestyle
I am attaining it now I'm in the process
of doing it and I do something every day
to get better at acting and I think that
there's there's a lot there's a lot of
uncertainty a lot of stuff that you
can't control but I do everything in my
power to control what I can control and
I can control my my productivity I can
control getting better at acting there
are things that can control so every
little thing I can do that that can you
know put me up there make make me a
better artist a you know a better person
I try to do that how does the martial
arts come into play well I mean it's
nice to decompress and hit some you
know I mean the artist you know it could
be really stressful being an actor and
not knowing when your next job is and
it's nice to go do something that that I
work at and I get better and it's such a
tangible thing like I do it and I rise
through the ranks and you're gonna rise
to the ranks because you work hard
acting it's not really a certain thing
like that it's just you do what you can
but but with martial arts it's like I
think it also keeps me humble cuz I you
know I I ice bar I go really hard and
there's always out some out there
there's always someone who could kick
your ass and I think it's you know I
think it's definitely humbled me a lot
because you know and also made me more
confident in a lot of ways and made me
more centered but it's for decompression
and in humility and you know some people
go to therapy III go to martial arts
when did you start martial arts ah man I
started like 107 and I took a while off
cuz I did all the childhood sports like
baseball basketball and then
high school I played water polo and then
went after my third year water polo I
had some friends who were getting into
Brazilian jiu-jitsu and I'd done that as
a kid and I was just started doing it
again and I fell back in love with it
and I've been doing it since my junior
of high school when I was like 15 I'm
like 2024 now so I've been doing it for
a while and then I started kickboxing
recently and I'd done a little wrestling
- would you advise other actors to
always have a hobby or always have
something else because it sounds like
the martial arts you can kind of like
maybe forget about entertainment for a
while yeah and just focus on that yeah I
think you gotta have other stuff in your
life definitely it makes you makes you
more whole makes you a more interesting
person
and I think it's also important to have
friends who are not in the industry like
I have a lot of friends so I just go and
I just shoot the with and I I can
have fun with and I don't necessarily
talk about my career at all or what I'm
doing or what I'm not doing or it's nice
to have that that you know that normalcy
right where people see you as again it's
just like oh thank you to go to my gym
you know and do that train with not the
actor or the guy pursuing a career
you